ils sont lycéens ou étudiants et ce soir
ils trouveront peut-être leur famille
pour du baby sitting
clémence est étudiante à l'université de
versailles saint quentin et ce mode de
rencontre
tim job dating lui plaît beaucoup j'ai
déjà fait à quelques années et ça avait
bien marché et parce que j'ai comme
beaucoup d'étudiants on n'est jamais
contre avoir un petit job on peut faire
aussi via des agences mais si c'est plus
compliqué je trouve c'est moins direct
là c'est plus vivant rencontre des gens
directement là ils peuvent être
ressentis sur le coup on donne notre cv
donc c'est un peu quand même sérieux il
voit à peu près qui on est déjà dès les
cinq premières minutes après plusieurs
entretiens pour échanger sur son
parcours et ses disponibilités
clémence ressort plutôt confiance plutôt
des retours positifs
il ya pas mal de familles qui sont
intéressés par mon profil impression on
verra bien organisée par le pôle
jeunesse de montigny le bretonneux cette
septième édition a attiré une
soixantaine de familles ça fonctionne
bien depuis la première année parce
qu'en fait ça répond à un besoin des
familles
qui recherchent à la rentrée des
solutions de garde soient ponctuels soit
régulière et ne savent pas trop où
trouver des jeunes
ça donne la possibilité de rencontrer
des jeunes qui sont dans la même commune
donc ça c'est un point positif c'est
vrai que je privilégiais le feeling
physique plutôt que des petites annonces
à qu'il faut éplucher et qui finalement
disent pas grand chose une nouvelle
cession de b b sides dating est
programmée samedi 23 septembre pour y
participer les inscriptions se font
auprès du pôle jeunesse